Hi, everyone.
My name is Elena Kon.
I'm a Software
Engineer at Google.
And today I'm going to
talk a bit about failure,
why I think it's important,
and how to embrace
it to become more awesome.
We all want to be awesome.
We all want to win at life.
And we all want
to be successful.
But how do we get there?
Often, our first reflex
is to be careful.
We say to ourselves, I'm going
to try and get this right
the first time, once
I'm good enough.
But the road to success is
almost never a smooth one.
In fact, it's
usually pretty bumpy.
No matter how
careful we are, only
by failing over and
over and over again,
do we eventually succeed.
So if we want to
be successful, it
is critical that
instead of avoiding it,
we learn how to deal
with and embrace failure.
Confidence is a key part of
our ability to embrace failure.
An article titled
"The Confidence Gap,"
that I recently
read made me think
more of why some people like the
confidence needed to succeed.
The article tries to
explain the observation
that women lack the
same level of confidence
as their male counterparts.
It boldly states that, "If life
were one long grade school,
women would be the undisputed
rulers of the world."
What this means is that
girls do just as well as
boys in school-- by some
measures, even better.
But as soon as we're
done with school
and released out
into the real world,
we struggle to keep up with
boys' success-- especially
with the level of confidence
that they exhibit.
This is explained by the fact
that girls come into school
with a developmental
advantage, making it easier
for them to behave.
They then get praised a
lot for being perfect.
In turn, they begin to
crave this approval that
causes them to avoid failure
and take fewer risks.
Boys also tend to get
a lot more scolding,
as studies show that
in the classroom,
boys were observed
to get eight times
more criticism than girls.
Naturally, boys learn to
take failure with stride.
Furthermore, boys toughen
each other up outside
of the classroom.
They tease each other, point
out each others' limitations,
and call each other
butt-heads and morons.
This makes such criticism
lose a lot of its power.
This playground mentality
encourages them later as men,
to let other people's tough
remarks slide off their backs.
The result of this upbringing is
that girls avoid taking risks,
because they're more
fearful of failure.
When they do take
risks, they're not
as experienced and
prepared as boys to deal
with the potential failure.
So when they do fail,
they're typically more
negatively affected by it.
This in turn causes them to be
even more apprehensive to take
risks in the future.
But being able to
overcome failure
that is typical of the
result of taking risk,
is essential for
confidence building.
While we can't go back in
time to change the past,
to take more risks and
make more mistakes,
we can hopefully try to reverse
some of the habits that make us
more risk averse I want to
start by providing some context,
and setting the stage
for how I got interested
in this topic, how I
failed many, many times,
and how I've learned
to deal with failure,
appreciate it, and use it
to build up my confidence,
to help me take more risks.
My first undisputed, very
public failure in life,
was when I got a an F
on a calculus pop quiz
that I was entirely
unprepared for.
This freaked me out
so much, that it
kicked me into high gear
and motivated me to study.
As a result, for the next test
in this class, I got 108%.
Yes, there were some
bonus questions.
When I later reflected
on this experience,
I realized that failing
this quiz actually inspired
and motivated me to work
harder to try to succeed.
I found a silver lining here.
I had discovered this
intrinsic motivating force
that could help propel me
through difficult times.
Ever since that experience,
I've become much better
at dealing with failure.
Instead of getting stuck
at step one, being upset,
I'm able to pretty quickly
jump to step two, where
I get super excited about what
is to follow; the purposeful,
hopefully rewarding hard work.
If we take some
time to reflect, we
can all probably think of
many times when we failed.
And all of us over
time have learned
to deal with failure
in one way or another.
Some people need
space to recover,
and others are able
to laugh it off.
But what if we could harness
that failure to succeed?
The key idea that I
want to point out here,
is that if we re-frame
these failures that
are potential precursors
to success, then
we can use that to
build up our confidence.
Beyond the idea of just
re-wiring your brain,
I do hope to leave you
with some more practical,
hopefully easy to implement tips
and tricks to embrace failure.
The first is to
minimize the risk.
Set small milestones that are
independent of external factors
like people or
particular events.
For example, when I was
interviewing for jobs,
one time I set a small
milestone to look
into the interviewer's eyes
when communicating with them.
I had a really hard
time doing that,
and was trying to
improve it at the time.
So I did it.
And despite not
getting the job, I
was actually really proud
of my small accomplishment.
Another way to minimize risk
is to anticipate problems
and prepare for them.
Whenever I encounter an
ambitious problem or situation,
I try to imagine
what Batman would do.
It's widely known that
given enough prep time,
Batman could win any fight.
I want to be the same way.
After spending a few years
in the tech industry,
I decided I wanted
to switch jobs.
But before I began
interviewing, I
spent weeks relearning
CS concept and practicing
problems.
Feeling prepared when
I came to interviews
gave me the confidence I needed
to calmly tackle problems
that I was not at
all familiar with.
The next thing is to
find the silver lining.
When I competed in
swing dancing, often
I wouldn't win first place.
But being put on the spot
to the something cool
with the audience watching
and cheering you on,
gives you the adrenaline
and encouragement
to try some really creative
moves that fit the music.
So oftentimes I would get
one or two great new moves
from competing, that
I could take with me
and developed later,
and potentially
use again in competition
when it's been perfected.
This was a huge win for me.
Finally, pat yourself on
the back heavily and often.
The idea here is
that doing so helps
strengthen the connection
between success and failure,
and gets you the
courage when you're
contemplating taking a risk.
One thing I do is I
keep an 'I'm awesome'
email label and folder.
I put 'thank you' and
'congratulation' emails there,
my performance review,
any great ideas,
and anything else I can
associate with success.
Whenever I'm sad
because I just failed
or hesitant to
try something new,
I go and look at this
folder and remember
all of my accomplishments.
And more importantly, I
remember all of the failures
that it took to get there,
and think to myself, yeah,
I am awesome.
And pretty much instantaneously,
feel better and encouraged
to try something new.
While a large part of my talk
was focused on women building
confidence, as you may
have realized by now,
these tips aren't just
relevant to women.
But really could be used
by any person of any age.
So now that hopefully
you've thought
about re-framing failures
as a precursor to success,
and have some ideas on
how to deal with failure,
go create your 'awesome' folder,
and try something new that you
think may be rewarding but take
you outside of your comfort
zone, like that dance class,
or that project at work
no one will touch.
And start filling up
your 'awesome' folder
with accomplishments, to help
you accomplish even more.
Thank you.